Майже 16 років німецький уряд очолює Анґела Меркель.
Перша в історії канцлерка провела Німеччину крізь багато криз - фінансову, єврокризу,
кризу біженців, коронавірус. І від самого початку брала активну участь
у пошуку дипломатичного рішення кризи на Сході України. Хто продовжить її курс щодо України?
І який кандидат у канцлери є, так би мовити, найбільш "проукраїнським"?
Кандидата від ХДС/ХСС Арміна Лашета багато хто вважає копією Меркель
у стратегічно важливих питаннях. Неяскравий, обережний та прагматичний.
Щоправда, в минулому до Лашета приліпився імідж надто м'якого у ставленні до Кремля.
Це сталося у 2014 році. Тоді після російської анексії Криму він застерігав від демонізації Путіна.
За це Лашета почали вважати "путінферштеєром" - тобто тим, "хто розуміє Путіна".
Але нині санкції проти Москви за анексію Криму Лашет всіляко підтримує і нещодавно підтвердив,
що скасовувати їх зарано. Та й загалом критикував російське керівництво неодноразово.
Анексія однозначно порушує міжнародне право. Не можна дозволити знову змінювати кордони в Європі.
Однак відносини потрібно будувати не лише на цьому конфлікті.
Час для зняття санкцій ще не настав.
Однак вже нині треба говорити про те, як зробити їх непотрібними.
Лашет ніколи не ставив під питання необхідність запуску газопроводу "Північний потік - 2",
навіть після отруєння Олексія Навального та відмови російської влади розслідувати злочин.
Але стати канцлером Лашету буде не так просто.
Потрібно, аби його ХДС не лише отримала найбільше голосів на виборах до Бундестагу,
де головним конкурентом стануть Зелені. За нинішніх рейтингів коаліція у старому форматі
із соціал-демократами вже неможлива і треба буде, ймовірно, шукати нових коаліційних партнерів.
Можливо, навіть Зелених, які традиційно завжди були в опозиції до ХДС/ХСС.
У німецьких Зелених нині всі шанси досягти рекордного для себе результату
на парламентських виборах у Німеччині.
Їхній кандидатці у канцлери Анналені Бербок - лише 40 років.
На початку правління Меркель їй було лише 24, вона тільки-но приєдналася до партії,
якою керував Йошка Фішер, тодішній очільник МЗС в уряді Ґергарда Шредера.
Бербок - наймолодша претендентка у канцлери всіх часів,
а також - єдина жінка-кандидатка на цьогорічних перегонах.
У зовнішній політиці Бербок має репутацію жорсткого критика дій Росії в Україні.
Для України також важливо, що вона підтримує партійну лінію проти добудови "Північного потоку-2".
Це обумовлюється вимогами Зелених зменшувати використання викопних видів палива.
"Північний потік - 2" розколює Європу. Цей газопровід підриває
наш стратегічний зовнішньополітичний суверенітет і суперечить
нашим енергетичним та кліматичним цілям у ЄС.
Анналена Бербок - енергійна і харизматична, однак не має жодного досвіду урядування.
Тому невідомо, як її погляди зміняться, коли вона вийде з опозиції і отримає реальну владу.
Головна тема Зелених - це усе-таки не зовнішня політика, а захист клімату.
Так чи інакше, а зважаючи на нинішній сплеск популярності, уявити собі майбутній уряд Німеччини
без Зелених практично неможливо, переконані експерти.
Важко собі уявити формування уряду без участі в ньому Зелених.
Вони завжди присутні, про яку б коаліцію не йшлося. Причому іноді Зелені навіть
на першому місці, що для німецької партійної традиції є справжньою революцією.
Експертка берлінського Інституту європейської політики Людмила Мельник вважає,
що найкращим для України був би сценарій, за якого Зелені увійдуть до коаліції
та висунуть свого міністра закордонних справ.
На політику буде впливати, як пройде процес підписання коаліційної угоди,
які партії займуть у міністерстві місця, адже вони мають змогу висувати
своїх кандидатів на посаду міністрів. І мені здається, що якщо Анналена Бербок
займе посаду міністра закордонних справ, то це для України навіть буде вигідніше.
І зараз активно обговорюють саме це. Що у неї є можливості
очолити міністерство закордонних справ Німеччини.
А це партія, яка має нині всі шанси опинитися в опозиції після багатьох років
урядування разом з християнськими демократами - СДПН.
Її кандидат Олаф Шольц сам не очолює партію, а є нині міністром фінансів та віцеканцлером.
Соціал-демократи у питаннях співпраці з Росією дотримуються позиції,
що економічне партнерство має бути поза політикою та критикують санкції США проти "Північного потоку - 2".
Такі санкції є серйозним втручанням у внутрішні справи Німеччини та Європи та у наш суверенітет.
Ми категорично проти них. Більше того, це є неприйнятним у колі друзів, яких об'єднує НАТО.
Що ж до війни на Донбасі й анексії Криму позиція Олафа Шольца узгоджується
із загальною партійною лінією СДПН.
А вона - приязніша до Москви, порівняно з іншими німецькими партіями.
Якщо порівнювати ХДС і СДПН, яку представляє Олаф Шольц,
то, звичайно, СДПН є більш дружньо налаштована до Росії партія.
І все ж таки, я думаю, в Німеччині існує політика продовження.
І сам курс, незважаючи на те, хто прийде до влади, сам курс щодо України буде продовжений.
Тож, хто б не став наступним канцлером Німеччини, підтримка України буде
і надалі одним із пріоритетів у зовнішній політиці Берліна.